i wasn't like profoundly communicating
like
i was wrong it was more so like making
small corrections and saying i used to
think this but now i think this because
i was told
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and
i'm super excited for this interview
today
uh a gentleman a young gentleman who has
uh
done an incredible job in my uh humble
opinion from the outside of producing
meaningful content to his community and
we're going to find out how
hiram yarbrough's journey began his
backstory and then i'm really you know
one of the reasons i reached out to him
which is rare for me but i think he has
a perspective and an opportunity
to help a lot of listeners understand
some of the contemporary opportunities
in content creation and so i'm really
excited to have him here
how are you good i'm great how are you
i'm well
so let's get like let's actually go way
to the way way beginning
give me give me two minutes of the
origin story were you where were you
born what kind of kid were you what were
your interests let's get right into that
first
for sure so i was born in a tiny country
town called paulden arizona
it was i grew up on a cattle ranch my
dad was a cowboy
literally in the middle of nowhere a
little country kid
and grew up as always a pretty
idealistic and
a big dreaming kid i always wanted to
get out of there first of all but do big
things i just didn't know how or when
um and when do you remember
thinking that way five six seven eight
literally as soon as i
started having thoughts i wanted to
travel the world i wanted to do big
things i
i was always the kid who could never
decide what i wanted to be when i grew
up because i just wanted to be
everything
um i and i remember coming to that
conclusion when i was in middle school
just thinking you know i just wanted a
job where i could just do
every single type of job out there um
because if you think of you
did you think of yourself creative did
you think i want to be an actor or a
musician
did you think about being was it
entrepreneurial were you like i want a
business like
how did it kind of frame in those early
days you know in the early days it was
naturally entrepreneurial although i
don't think i recognized it to be
entrepreneurial um
but early on i did want to do you know i
wanted to be an author and then i wanted
to you know be a
a traveler and a you know national
geographic photographer and all these
different things but it wasn't until i
was early in high school that's when i
started first creating my businesses i
started doing online website design
um that i really started to grasp the
idea of just being an
entrepreneur really was my passion
during high school was really
i mean i remember when i was seven years
old i started you know
learning how to build websites and i was
constantly always that little kid who
was
making new businesses and trying to like
sell my family on my products and
businesses
all the time but it wasn't until i was
in high school where i was able to
quit my um like bagging job at a grocery
store
to do website design and i was just
booking clients left and right like
crazy
where i started to realize okay i think
something along the lines of building my
own business
um is definitely where i'm interested in
and then what happened
well and then i ended up moving to
hawaii um kind of out of nowhere
your family expecting you just me just
me by myself i moved here i'd never been
here before i didn't know anyone so
um it was just a brand new was was that
out of offense or was that defense were
you struggling and said i have to get
the hell out of here or were you
oh my god i need to go see those you
know
volcanoes and waves and that culture so
was it was
were you in a point of your life where
it was needed to escape or was it a
point in your life where you just
wanted to go on the offense for the
adventure it was a little bit of both
um i definitely was in a really toxic um
home environment to where
i felt like i was you know being
suppressed so many different ways my
dreams were just not being able to be
accomplished so i
um wanted to leave that i was oh how old
was i 18
maybe just turned 19. somewhere around
there um but i also wanted to be in a
place that was really culturally diverse
growing up on a
cattle ranch you don't even already see
the most diverse
populations so that was kind of the
appeal um also i hate the cold so i was
like where is the place
did you you knew nobody in hawaii no one
i didn't know anyone
so what did you do it was hard but it
was amazing um
yeah so i first started um going to
school i was studying entrepreneurship
and international cultural studies and
anthropology
um and i just rapidly started learning
what i want to but i kind of quickly
started to realize that school exactly
really wasn't the thing for me
i felt yeah exactly i felt so boxed in
um
and i felt like i was being forced to
take classes that i just had no interest
in and i'm all about practical
application
and once i realized well first of all i
was absolutely broke
i was i had 25 cents a day for food no
money whatsoever i wasn't getting um
you know assistance did you ever
get so deterred that you thought about
leaving or were you just fighting
through you were just committed
or mixed with you again i was fighting
through
um because i was like you know i had
always just imagined myself
as you know an academic someone who was
going to get like lots of degrees and
everything
so you thought so you thought we had a
little technical difficulty there so
let's pick this right back up
so you thought that you were going to
have all these degrees now you're
realizing not for me
so what happens next so i ended up
dropping out um
because i realized very early on like
hiram
if you're an entrepreneur and you're
building your own businesses it doesn't
matter how many
degrees you have it's not going to
matter to investors and to other you
know business people alike
so i ended up dropping out and um
started just like working a normal job
while pursuing
side passions one of which was youtube
so
let's talk about that did youtube take
off for you did it take time like
help everybody who's listening
understand the journey
yeah i mean it definitely took time i'd
say for the first part for the first
year and a half i was on that was
partially i started in 2017. um
it was i'd say it's probably my fault i
wasn't really fully committed i was
uploading maybe like twice a month very
irregularly um
no really um clear path as to exactly
who i
wanted to be what type of content i
wanted to create it was more so just
focused on skin care and trying to help
you know educate on the basics
it wasn't it was very even at that point
it was very focused on skin care
yep i realized right away like i i had
been working as a makeup artist but i i
realized makeup was
really really saturated and there was a
great need for skin care information and
knowledge but no one was really
filling that void at that time so i
decided to start you know filling that
void by creating content
and specifically focused on skincare and
at that point in your career
how educated were you on skincare let's
say in comparison to the way you are now
um not very much i was definitely more
new to it i wanted to share the little
bit of knowledge as i had but i was able
to grow collectively through
you know information i got from
dermatologists and chemists from my
audience holding me accountable from my
own personal research studies all that
kind of stuff
did you have the confidence to when you
first started that
to be upfront with the audience and say
hey i'm learning in this journey or did
you do
what 99.9 of the people do which is
maybe
maybe try to have the confidence maybe
the fake confidence of knowing more than
you did but then once you realized
that there was too many people and too
many eyes on it to fake the funk
did it change your trajectory of how you
spoke about it and you doubled
tripled and quadrupled down on education
while layering humility
when you weren't 100 sure because i
think this is where you can help a lot
of people
like i think a lot of people make that
mistake and i actually genuinely don't
know if you did or didn't
i'm just curious if you when i asked
that question where does your mind go
yeah i mean early on very early on in my
channel i was called out by
multiple subscribers for like spreading
wrong information and i
immediately started shifting my content
to fall in line with you know the
feedback i was getting
i wasn't like over the top transparent
in the sense
of well not transparent i wasn't like
profoundly communicating like i was
wrong it was more so
like making small corrections and saying
i used to think this but now i think
this because
i was told this this and this and i was
called out and i was uh you know made
aware that i was wrong and that was that
was something i wanted has that
has that experience helped you now that
you've built such a big platform
in having empathy for other people that
are you know because
because it's a really interesting
journey
actually let's because a lot of audience
probably doesn't know this why don't you
give people a sense of
your community you know obviously you
know followers aren't the end-all be-all
but just as a sense of context
give us a little sense of what's going
on with you on tiktok and
and youtube these days than anything
else yeah yeah for sure um
so skincare has become a lot more
popular and because that i've been able
to grow quite rapidly on on youtube in
december or around the end of last year
i hit 100
000 followers on youtube and i'm now at
3.75
3.8 million somewhere around there and
um tick tock i started posting
in march and um and now at 6.5 million
do you believe that you believe your
hyper growth on tick tock
led to the explosion of youtube
subscribers
you know funny enough i think it was
partial um because i
was already at i think somewhere around
like almost two million subscribers when
i um well no that's a lie
i think yeah it definitely played a part
um i had hit one
i've been i've been sleeping i've been
seeing that a lot i've been seeing a lot
of people's
youtube and instagram explode
from the reality of the virality loop of
tick tock and it's been really
interesting i think
your generation um which you know is a
younger generation
or a generation that first hits pay dirt
on tick tock has been more strategic and
thoughtful this is a general statement
but has been has collectively been more
strategic
of building out twitter and instagram
and youtube whereas i noticed
five seven nine years ago the people
that were hitting on
instagram stayed isolated and same with
other platforms and and i've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
that um and was curious if you had
experienced that
i mean yeah the benefit and the whole
reason why i was initially attracted to
tick-tock was just the extreme virality
that can come
so rapidly and i will say on youtube
about what's that's where i got my first
sport of growth you know hitting a
hundred thousand at the end of the year
and then
in like february or march hitting a
million but that happened
that's insane did that happen on the
back of one or two videos or was it just
consistent
just consistent funny enough there
wasn't like one viral video or anything
it just was like
upload after upload after upload just
started gaining a lot of traction
how did you how did you deal with the
transformation of wait a minute this
might be happening right you
you've always we started this
conversation with you're dreaming about
some version of this as a kid you're in
december you had a hundred thousand
which is not even a year ago which is
remarkable
but a very big different place than
where are where you are today
as you and i speak so what what is
starting to go through your mind
in january and february in early march
let's say right before covid because
that probably obviously
added new realities into your mind like
when you let's just let's just try to
pick on valentine's day
are you are you looking in the mirror
and saying oh [ __ ] it's happening
because when you have that kind of
sustained growth
you definitely feel it you can sense
something's happening
was that a challenge was that
unbelievably exciting like
how did you quantify that first quarter
of of this year where you're like oh
[ __ ] this is happening
yeah i mean it was mostly unbelievably
exciting thankfully i really didn't feel
any pressure or any like anxiety about
it it was more so just standing back in
amazement i definitely was a little bit
more strategic in the content that i was
creating obviously seeing what was
working and saying okay i'm gonna start
replicating that strategy one of the
things that really exploded
was my reaction video so i just started
doing those which has really sustained
my growth
um but thankfully i didn't feel any like
define define
reaction videos for everybody in the
audience yeah yeah so i do videos on my
channel called specialist reacts where i
react
to you know people doing terrible things
their face or celebrity skincare
routines or tick tock
crazy skincare videos just different
things and i think i always make sure to
capture my genuine reactions and people
i think gravitate towards that kind of
like humor entertainment also paired
with helpful skincare information
with this so what
what's happening now give give an
insight to the parents or the youngsters
or the people in your bracket right now
that have aspirations for
influence or business built around a
personal brand
what's the state of the union of your
world now what what what's different
today than a year ago today
let's go let's do it yeah i mean i'd say
what's different today with access to a
platform like tick tock it is
easier to go viral than ever um i'm used
to you know youtube and twitter and
instagram where you kind of have to play
the long game you know you really have
to trust in the algorithm for a long
term which usually weeds out the
majority of people
tick talk i'm seeing so many people who
their first video gets over a million
views
within a day just crazy virality and
what about for you i mean
do you have do you have brand deals that
are different do you have
a team around you that's different like
give me because i think a lot of people
like to learn
the aspects of what happens when it hits
what
what's different with your team without
prying the economic opportunities
just from an education standpoint of the
growth of an influencer at this
white heat moment like a year ago today
you had how many people with you
how how about now like let's start with
that one actually
yeah a year ago today i had one person
um who's my manager
um just my friend that i had employed
because she
believed in my channel as much as i did
today i have a team
i mean technically more people than i
can count kind of assisting in it but my
direct team
is like uh six people that i work with
directly like
on a day-to-day basis for things like
editing management
coordination the production team stuff
like that the production team in your
world
yeah essentially production team but
then i also have you know a management
agency and you know a financial team and
stuff
so about that and has that been hard or
has that been great
it it's been a mixture of both not going
to lie there is no manual
out there unfortunately for like how to
go about this
extreme level of growth and for me if
what i did for so long was just
reference
what other you know creators were
experiencing but very quickly the
level of growth i was seeing i was like
i've never seen this before so i don't
really have anyone to reference to go
off of
so it has been very bumpy but i think
i've been fortunate in
really finding good people to partner
with good teams work with and
thankfully i'm pretty financially
responsible
as is um so dealing with this you know
kind of massive growth in you know
economic opportunity i've been able to
you know go about how much
how much how much of a challenge is it
for an influencer that sits on
you know reacting and focusing on the
quality of brands
to then do brand deals and let's put you
in a picture
you know it must be a challenge you know
actually where do you stand on clean
products or like what's your positioning
in the in kind of the skin care universe
because i know you carry a lot of
i mean at this you know just to educate
everybody who's listening
you know especially with a younger
skewing audience
this young man's voice much like you
know i lived it i lived in 2006 and
seven and eight
with young people in america drinking
wine my opinions
and that's what it is um carried some
weight and wineries
both struggled with that and were
excited about that
when i was in the white heap moment but
that was the 2006-78 year of youtube
when 90 of the world wasn't on the
platform the sheer size and scale of
audiences today in comparison
so you know it must be crazy for you to
know that
some of the biggest brands in the world
and the biggest you know consumer
package good companies in the world
know exactly who you are and and talk
about you in boardrooms and strategize
on
how to get your support um emerging
brands
probably are sitting around right now
who are about to launch a brand saying
if we can just get hired to like give us
a good review
like that how do you balance not
becoming too egotistical
staying humble um trying to find
business opportunities
for you and your future family and wants
and dreams
while staying responsible to your
mission like
you know there's a lot there to balance
brother yeah no it's it's a lot
and i think for me i don't let myself
think about it too much um
honestly i feel like when you let
yourself think about like the exact
depth and the exact impact of like what
your words will
will make or whatever i think that's
kind of like a a bit of a tricky path i
try to balance
scared of that at times like [ __ ] i'm
about to pan this thing
and like that's gonna make a lot of
people upset
or like happy yeah you know because like
sometimes you're like listen i lived it
you know i'm gonna do this for my
audience ah [ __ ] there's somebody's
livelihood
on the other side of this you know like
you know and listen i think
you also i'm sure playing the humble
card which realized look i've got a
hyper growth platform but there's a
million voices in the category so it's
not like
my pro or con is making or breaking but
it's starting to carry some real juice
and
that is a big responsibility yeah i mean
for me i
always just view as as long as i'm
acting from a really moral and ethical
standpoint and making sure that i
am as you know grounded and um
you know really empathetic as possible
with all my decisions
with the way i view everything um that's
the way to go i also have set a
standards of like kind of what you're
talking before my
standard my opinions around skincare are
very
very like specific and holding myself to
that
allows me to navigate give me some give
me some i think some people would enjoy
it
yeah for example um one of the things
that's known for my brand i really don't
like fragrance um i just don't think
it's necessary in skincare and when i
see fragrance it
just it is a pet peeve of mine because
it excludes an entire group of people
that aren't able to access
those products because of fragrance
allergies and sensitivity so that's one
thing that in my brand review videos i
really call them out for just saying
like brands you need to have products
that are accessible to people who have
fragrance allergies
it's not right that all of your products
are only fragranced and
excluding an entire group of people um
also talk about sustainability
practices when i see that the products
are not recyclable or that it's
unnecessary waste
i i think for me i'm my audience accepts
my really authentic voice that i don't
have a problem just like
calling them out and i think one thing
that really does kind of humble me is
at the end of the day like i'm still
sitting in a room by myself talking to
the camera
just like i did when i started and i
realized no one's watching my videos
and so for me i see people watching my
videos as a bonus
to what i love doing which is creating
videos um people watching is just the
bonus
you know the icing on top of the cake
who was the first person
celebrity or brand that reached out to
you that you literally went into the oh
my god oh my god i cannot believe xyz
just dm'd me or liked my video
oh that's a really good question i'd say
when um
carly kloss wanted to collaborate you
were the first time where i was like
[ __ ]
okay this isn't just youtube this is
like this is a huge and she wants to
collaborate with little me
you know that's where i think it's
before that but that was a huge moment
don't [ __ ] me here because i really
want to help a lot of people are
listening
did you at that point know there was
juice going and something like this was
possible
or was it did kyle did she find you
early enough where you were like i can
actually not [ __ ] believe this and
don't try to go humble around
because i think it's important when i
get reached out when i got started
getting reached out to
a list caliber individuals
i already knew that it made sense to me
because i knew something was happening
much more than let's say in 2007 when
the conan o'brien show
so the conan o'brien show reached out to
me in the first year i was on youtube to
put me on the show
nice i genuinely clicked the email to
see if it was like one of those emails
where it was really one of my buddies
making up a fake email
because at that point i wasn't in the
mindset of like this could happen
so where were you on that were you of
the place where you already already had
a lot of hype going
or was that early enough where you were
like i can actually not believe this
the hype had already started a little
bit to where i started to really capture
what you know really who i was and what
my space you know my place in the space
would be for a long time it was just
kind of like oh if i get 100 000
subscribers
that'll be the best thing ever dream
come true which it is
but now it's you know after that after i
started seeing rapid growth i started to
realize
okay i obviously have a much bigger role
in this space and so
yeah i i think it was right at the
beginning of that understanding
what what are you most worried about
these days with having this kind of
platform is when i say that what comes
to mind
is it about making the right decisions
to maximize the moment
is it is it having a video that goes
viral for the wrong reason and dealing
with all that ramifications
is it um burning out
from this category but having like
there's a lot of things that would make
sense to me
i gave you three examples is there any
when i say what you most worry about
because at this point and i'm going to
make some assumptions here
but please clarify if i'm right or wrong
because i want the audience to learn
from this
you're probably making dollars that you
didn't anticipate or legal or you
dreamed about
how old are you yes i'm 24. right you're
you're extremely young man you're making
a dot you're making financial
success that you probably it sounds like
dream dub
and thought probably for a lot of
reasons listening to your story
you thought could be possible but now it
is happening so there's that
um so there's that there's just a lot
going on for this
someone this young you know i remember i
remember
um you know i just think about so many
people coming through my office in the
last year charlie
and addison like i'm thinking about all
those conversations and where it leads
to
give an insight to somebody who thinks
you're so lucky
of some of your concerns anxieties of
what happens when you get to this level
of pedestal like what what is it for you
yeah
yeah i don't usually like to be vocal
about it but there are a lot of
stressors there are a lot of things i'd
say my most stressful thing is ensuring
the longevity and sustainability of my
presence
you understand more than anyone the
internet is a place where people can
just
shoot up and then boom disappear out of
nowhere and really navigating that and
surviving
that is is extremely difficult and i
think for me
um my mindset is so rooted in like
i have to maximize every every
opportunity right now because this may
not be available next year i may not be
getting this level of views this level
of attention next year so i have to
maximize every opportunity
and with that you know comes essentially
over now you know burnout you know we're
agreeing to too many things because you
know
you're i'm almost i'm so stressed all
the time about
that but yeah yeah you can ask a
question on that because i'm passionate
no [ __ ] like true friends right now
let's make pretend we're super best
friends
super fast go like let's make pretend
nobody's listening do you in your heart
believe that you're a one-hit wonder or
do you think you can sustain this for a
decade
i think i can just sustain this phrase
so that's my that's my sense of watching
you from afar
so let me say this i hit in 2006
it's 2020 right and i feel like i
haven't hit
and i haven't started if you j i'm
telling you my friend with all my heart
if you actually believe that i actually
believe you that's why i wanted to ask
you i wanted to hear it for myself
you need to take a huge exhale because
you will because if you
because what you talked about was so
important i knew i would be too because
i enjoyed the process
not the accolades that came with it not
the money not the
pseudo fake you know influence or fame i
knew
that i just liked it and i think you
have a real shot i think the biggest
vulnerability you have at 24 with this
level of power and that's what it is
is you walking around saying i have all
these teenage young girls
listening to my advice in a real way and
that's that's truth
i mean you know i know it because i
watch the game the amount of
10 to 18 year olds and that's what's so
fascinating right you're seeing
nine 10 11 year olds really take i mean
there's 11 year olds that know more
about skin care i would argue that the
average 11 year old today
knows more about skincare than the
average 40 year old 20 years ago knew
about skin care
levels are through the roof you know i
could see how you could be like [ __ ]
this is a lot of power like you just
need to stay in the pocket
of not getting too high on yourself and
if you can
control that you can walk to success i
really believe that brother
thank you thank you so much for that
advice yeah i mean my my stress and
anxiety is usually rooted around like
i think this fear of like you know going
away
yeah yeah and not not so much from like
a from a clout perspective but more so
just from like a um
you know growing up in the environment i
did it was always a very like you have
to survive
because you're no one is there for you
and i think being in that environment
has
kind of instilled this fear in me to
where i'm always like i have to work as
hard as i can yeah but you're absolutely
right
the other thing is being thoughtful
about your money i heard you yes
earlier say you're responsible it's
really about buying things
that you genuinely need and genuinely
want
not just going through the motions
because you have it people
people sometimes have like their wallet
on fire when they have money in it
as if they need to spend it i think one
of the things that gives calm to people
that
go through what you're going through
right now is not spending it
which then allows them to be a little
less anxious i actually really believe
that
yeah no i mean when you grow this
quickly at least for me
stability is something that is not as
commonplace and for me
the the warmest sense of stability i
could find is just making sure my
day-to-day life
did not change at all and i love it that
way i love not having my dates
what do you live about i love hawaii
oahu yep still and i i love it i want
i like it being the same i like my
day-to-day life being you know
pretty normal because i feel like if if
say if i were to live in l.a and was
around like influencer culture a lot a
lot every single day i
i don't think i'd be in the same
position and i don't think i'd be able
to stay grounded um
meet just me personally because you know
you're
surrounded by that right every second
you're getting dm like yo come here
do this show up to this yeah what about
what about what about going to public
like
like i assume because you have interest
in this you find yourself going to
sephora or alta or some of these places
are people
like how are you dealing with like the
the cliche scenario of like
four 15 year old girls freaking their
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i love it because i view them
as friends i didn't know i had and when
i see people recognize me in public i
see them as like
you are this person who has invested so
much time into learning about me and
engaging with my content
now i get to learn about you and who you
are and like
develop this relationship that i didn't
know you know was present so
i love it it's very humbling to me and
it's a it's a moment for me to
get away from the internet and just
express in person my gratitude and my
thanks
for you know everything that my audience
has built for me so i i really enjoy it
what do you consume podcasts tik tok
accounts or other influencers
uh netflix what are you currently
consuming
i consume a lot of tik tok um all
different kinds
and it's still youtube i do a lot of
humor and i do a lot of business
it's my passion i love humor because for
me seeing
the way people kind of like rapid fire
through entertainment
it kind of inspires me to do a better
job of that in my videos because i
always want my videos to be entertaining
not to people who are interested in skin
care to everyone to you know no matter
who you are to make people who are not
interested in skincare
interested in skincare but also business
to be able to apply those strategies to
what i'm doing and
and anything stand out recently in
consumption patterns like specifically a
podcast or a show or
an influencer or a content provider
anything oh that is
that is so difficult because even even
with my tick tock
um i'm always just consuming are you are
you
are you and for you mainly or you have a
secretary for you or you
yeah what about what about do let me ask
you an interesting question
do you feel that you have the permission
to do something completely left field on
your channel
like do you think that you could make a
cooking video right now or could make a
tick tock around
pancakes or do you feel a little bit the
pressure
of the category you're in and
and what's needed to let's say
subconsciously in your own mind
feed the algorithm and if i do this
video about water balloons
it might not do as well and maybe that
[ __ ] me up for my next 15 skincare
videos
speak about the life of the of the jails
that i you know content producers are
making and do you actually feel that
and can you share a story of wanting to
break out of it or trying to break out
of it and not doing well or doing it or
where are you at with yeah my perception
of this new reality
i mean that's a fear i never want to
pigeonhole myself into one specific
niche that when that niche kind of isn't
as popular that i
go down with it sort of thing um i have
i have done it i made a second channel
called selfless i did a video talking
about how i was a humanitarian and why i
regret it
and that video i think has over two
million views it's my first video
but you felt that you needed to go
different channel than to go in your
main
feed and is that because of the concern
of what
will it do off of this thing that is the
golden goose because it's an important
insight that i think will help people
the algorithm yeah i do worry about
disrupting the algorithm by
diversifying my content too drastically
um i think there is a benefit to
aligning yourself with a very specific
niche um
but you know that's also the benefit i
see in growing other platforms as well
that's why my tic tac is a little
different and my instagram is a little
different
um from my youtube channel and my
instagram i like to be purely just
photo personality based not skincare
whatsoever tic toc i like to be humor
with the balance of skincare and then
youtube
mostly skincare that's where i find a
little bit more justification for that
but yeah i do have a little bit of
disruption
have you podcasting have you do you have
one i apologize i don't know have you
considered one
yes definitely considering um potential
planning phase right now
so um yeah i'm excited about developing
that
book have you considered oh book
i'm sorry um yeah no definitely i mean
my dream since i was younger was to be
an author i think i just want to wait
for the right time um for a book i think
it's a good idea to not just like over
saturate um in terms of so many content
especially when focused on longevity so
i'm trying to be very strategic in how i
approach that but absolutely but
that's always been a dream have you
considered linkedin
because so many in that audience would
not be aware of you
but could probably get a ton of benefit
from your skin care advice
which would then oh you know what's
really funny people that follow me know
about two years ago i started getting
very loud about
about both tick tock and linkedin at the
same time and it played out in real life
i did quite well on both platforms and
sure enough my litmus test is the is the
airport because i'm always there
who comes up to me and all of a sudden
you know obviously in 2020
it became a lot more 65 year old
businessmen and women
and 12 year olds and 11 year olds
at the airport and so so i
i kind of view your generation your
genre
having huge potential on linkedin
because it has the same organic
reach dynamic that tick tock does yet
i don't see anybody call it under 30
seizing that opportunity and i think
your subject matter
plays extremely well to it something i
think you should consider
oh yeah absolutely thank you for
suggesting that i mean that's i think
one of the benefits of being in a
product-based
business niche is that you know you'll
automatically attract as opposed to just
purely humor or a prank channel or
something like that there's a lot more
opportunities when you're aligning
yourself with the
product based industry um and i've never
even considered linkedin so thank you
for suggesting that because
um i i haven't i'll have to start
looking into that that sounds amazing
before we get out of here anything i can
answer for you
oh i would just say in terms you've been
in the industry for a while you've seen
so many different creators rise and fall
you've seen the tides of
the influencer industry and you've seen
apps come and go
out of everything that you've seen what
is your like one piece of like
golden nugget advice your piece of
advice that you would want you know
a creator to to walk away with after
like a a
consultation with you or a meeting with
you or something like that something
that you've
seen yep so it's funny it's the same
reason i reached out to you
in a world where i do that very rarely i
think you have two of the core
ingredients for success
one is i call it cocoon culture
you're living in your cocoon you're
staying in hawaii
you're keeping it tight you're
self-aware enough to know if i go
to hype houses in l.a i'm going to
subconsciously
go out more often interact more often
get into the gossip
and the culture of it and that may veer
me out of my focus
so i think number one is cocoon culture
staying in your own cocoon
keeping it humble working on your craft
right now at your point instead of doing
that tripling down on your expertise
around
the products getting more educated on
the chemistry
and the way it all works uh number two
is
genuine patience and it's it's funny
this answer is
leading into how this interview went i
asked you if you really
really believe and i've asked that of
people and sometimes they say almost
everybody says yes
but i don't always believe that but i
believed you and i think if you believe
yourself
and know 34 year old i'm still going to
be a kid and i might be talking about
something
altogether different and 44 year old is
40 is gary's age right now
and he still doesn't feel super old to
me and that's 20 years from now
and i remember being 24 thinking 30 year
olds were old so i can't imagine what
you feel about me at 45
in a couple weeks no but i mean i mean
it i say with real empathy and
compassion sympathy and understanding
you know when you're 24 44 feels like a
very long time because it's such an
overwhelming percentage of your entire
life if i could give you and any other
influence or any other kid for that
matter
any advice is you would be blown away
that i feel like i'm your friend and
you're content i feel like we're the
same
it's just how you feel at this stage if
you're alive and happy you know what i
mean so
i would say lean heavily on patience
live in your cocoon
and then i would say challenge yourself
to make yourself uncomfortable
for example i love that you started
another channel to do other things
i would even challenge you as a friend
to putting out one piece of content that
shows a completely different side of
your reality on your main
main main thing because what that does
is it gets you comfortable with being
uncomfortable
and there's somebody who talks about
wine and the jets and business and
garage sales i'm all over the place the
algorithm
is not your enemy it's a figment of most
people's imagination
if you are good you will win and if you
genuinely love
fast food or or a new clothing style
or a new music artist i actually think
it's healthier
to break your pattern of being
subconsciously
um you know succumbing
to the algorithm and fearing it i think
it's healthy to break that so
i would say number three would be to do
things that are uncomfortable and
different
just to learn from them and get yourself
comfortable with the feedback being like
i don't like that go back to the other
thing or stay
i started making business content people
literally stay in your lane wine guy
just make
wine content wow that's crazy i can't
even imagine that
so i think i think take from that story
and kind of live that game
i know i i love that thank you you're
absolutely right when i started
i when i did like react videos and stuff
like that so not what i wanted to do
at all i literally did one reaction
video and i was like oh i'm never doing
that again
and it became and it became a thing it
became huge exactly and i think once
you know i think a lot of creators get
to this size to get comfortable creating
the same
type of content and i love that because
i i want to push myself to do things
let me give you one if you find yourself
being into something
that is similar to your audience too
like i'll give you a great one
i have no idea where you sit on candy
but if i'm you and i like candy
and i know where my audience sits i
probably do a real breakdown of candy
like just complete left field like a
random like like
and you know it's cliche like hey guys
i'm just trying new [ __ ]
like today instead of breaking down a
skin care product i'm gonna break down
nerds candies
here we go like like and i think you
know the occasional doing that
is really psychologically helpful for
people that
have had the great fortune of being in
the position that you're in which you
absolutely worked hard for
and were strategic and creative in and
and i'm really trying to get this
conversation out to more of the
influencers and i
can see it helping some people because
they get very stuck into what they think
they're supposed
to do which eventually corrodes and
cancerizes the thing they loved
oh wow that's amazingly put you couldn't
have
said it better yeah exactly yeah that's
that's one of my fears but thank you for
that knowledge tell everybody
tell everybody where to tell everybody
where they can find you before i let you
out of here
yeah so on youtube you can just find me
at hiram hyram and on instagram and tick
tock you can find me at skincare by
hiram
congratulations my friend thank you i
appreciate it thank you for having me
know if i can ever be a help
cheers of course hi everybody i hope you
enjoyed this interview please share
it please leave me comments let me know
if you want me to do more stuff like
this
the insights to some of the pioneers in
the current
state of the attention economy and so
thank you one more time
have a wonderful wonderful winter cheers
you too thank you
youtube what's up it's garyvee first of
all thank you so much i hope you're
doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon